welcome back everybody it looks like we
have a leak on the two post credits
scenes for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness uh let's get right
to it first we have the mid credit scene
and it goes
strange is sleeping after the events of
multiverse of badness and he has a
nightmare where he sees himself training
an apprentice
a ruined new york city a dead wong
dormammu's sister umar and a glimpse of
king the conqueror
he then wakes up with a third eye and
hears the voice of clia played by
charlize theron saying help me
and then the end credits scene deadpool
along with cable domino and vanessa are
exploring the illuminati facility due to
the illuminati's multiversal gates being
left open after the wanda fight deadpool
is joking with the bodies of some
members including making a reference to
the office deadpool then makes a joke
fourth wall break about patrick
stewart's professor x being dead again
for the third time and that's pretty
much it uh some things to take away from
this much like most of the other
supposed plot leaks we do have doctor
strange with a third eye and hearing the
voice of clea
as well as deadpool appearing with cable
domino and vanessa i have read that
before uh also the reference to the
office anyways let me know what you guys
think this one is definitely out there
if you guys do believe this is happening
please let me know down below if you
think that it's completely fake also
please let me know
uh for those of you who don't know yet i
am donating 25 of all video revenue to a
charity that my subscribers choose i
would really appreciate you guys to
continue coming back and if you don't
mind please subscribe i am doing this
every day i'll see you guys tomorrow